[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour moi tout a commencé un soir de
septembre 1980 le soir on est en
revanche choisi mon prénom
thomas comme l'apôtre je le précise pour
ceux qui sont pas familiers avec la
liturgie saint thomas
c'est celui qui ne croit que ce qu'il
voit quelque part sans le savoir est
dans une époque où la croyance et le
savoir sont très entremêlées au point
que la frontière est presque invisible
il m'avait prédestiné à me retrouver ici
aujourd'hui devant vous mais qu'est ce
que tu crois enfin
cette question j'ai très envie de vous
la poser à tous mais je voudrais vous
raconter l'histoire d'un jeune homme à
qui j'ai aussi très envie de poser cette
question chinoise brook néo zélandais
qui a décidé un jour de profiter d'une
disposition légale de son pays qui lui
permettait de poser une question au
gouvernement à condition de recueillir
suffisamment de signatures de citoyens
pour l'appuyer jusqu'ici tout va bien
et peut-être même que dans la salle il y
à de nombreuses personnes qui
souhaiteraient disposer ici en france de
telles mesures de démocratie directe
jusqu'ici tout va bien mais c'est là que
ça se corse un petit peu parce que la
question de shane elle est liée à sa
croyance et sa croyance c'est que son
voisin est un reptilien que son patron
est un reptilien et que comme ces
reptiles aux humanoïdes gouvernent le
monde en secret est bien john key le
premier ministre néo zélandais est lui
aussi un reptilien jusqu'ici tout va
bien
vous le savez l'important ce n'est pas
la chute c'est l'atterrissage en
l'occurrence le fait que chine et réussi
à réunir les signatures nécessaires pour
donner à sa question la force de la loi
et donc à soumettre le premier ministre
de son pays à des tests cliniques et
vétérinaire afin de démontrer qu'il
n'était pas un reptile déguisé en êtres
humains
il faut bien reconnaître un grand nombre
de nos concitoyens sont un petit peu
perdues ils ne savent plus à quel saint
se vouer
peut-être pourrions-nous leurs commandes
et saint-amand ils ne savent plus faire
le trier le bon grain de l'ivraie et
c'est quelque part assez normal si je
vous disais qui hier vendredi 13 les
résultats du loto sont sortis de cette
manière
1 2 3 4 5 6 vous y croyez vous pensez
bien entendu à une manipulation à une
arnaque peut-être même un complot eh
bien vous auriez tort et moi aussi
puisque j'y croirai pas plus que vous
pourtant tous les mathématiciens sont
formels la probabilité mathématique que
cette suite de chiffres un deux trois
quatre cinq six sortes est exactement la
même que pour tout autre combinaison de
chiffres
et pourtant notre cerveau refuse cette
possibilité refuse de nous laisser y
croire
bien souvent il préfère voir des
intentions là où il y aurait du hasard
c'est tout à fait normal
et d'ailleurs si vous vous rappelez de
vos jeunes années sur les bancs de
l'école
et bien vous allez vous souvenir que
quand vous aviez une bonne note
c'est parce que vous aviez travaillé que
vous aviez appris votre leçon en tout
cas c'était lié à vos qualités mais
quand vous aviez une mauvaise note
c'était parce que vous n'aviez pas
travailler parce que vous aviez trop
fait la fête avec vos copains jouer à la
console toute la nuit non c'est parce
que vous aviez été sacké tout ce que
nous réussissons nous l'attribuant à nos
qualités et tout ce que nous aura t'on
tous nos échecs
bien entendu c'est la faute des autres
les autres à cet enfer avec lesquels il
nous faut pourtant arriver à vivre mais
je le droit de penser qu'ici tous autant
que vous êtes vous êtes manipulés
il faut dire que vous avez pris une bien
mauvaise habitude une forme de réflexe
pavlovien à chaque fois que vous vient
une question qu'elle vous brûle les
lèvres hier vous ouvriez un livre
avant-hier peut-être une encyclopédie
mais aujourd'hui vous allez sur internet
et vous posez votre question à l'aide de
l'un des différents moteurs moteur de
recherche qui existe est la différence
entre les livres et internet
c'est la réponse qu'on vous donne est-ce
que sur internet la réponse qu'on vous
suggère en premier est la meilleure des
réponses celle qui contient le plus de
savoir où est celle qui a la plus grande
audience sur les réseaux vous l'avez
compris quel que soit le moteur que de
recherche que vous utilisez vous allez
vous retrouver confrontés à la même
problématique c'est l'audience et donc
la capacité des croyants à faire valoir
leurs croyances qui permet leur
représentation par les algorithmes
tout cela pose un immense problème un
problème auquel nous sommes tous
confrontés
ce problème concerne bien entendu les
journalistes comme moi les médias mais
aussi la totalité de la société
que se passera-t-il si demain les
croyants supplantent les rationalistes
sur les principales sources
d'information dont nous disposons et
bien afin de trouver peut être des
solutions
je vous propose est celle que j'ai
élaboré avec tout un tas de jeunes
collégiens et lycéens depuis deux ans je
me rends dans de nombreuses classes afin
de faire un travail d'éducation à
l'esprit critique et de vérification des
sources d'information le premier conseil
c'est d'apprendre à penser contre soi
même c'est à dire à remettre en cause
non pas le monde mais notre vision du
monde comme des cartes dans son poil en
son époque
ce n'est pas la réalité qu'il faut
remettre en cause mais notre vision de
la réalité
ce premier conseil en appel un deuxième
nous en avons parlé à propos du loto il
faut se méfier de ce que l'on a envie de
croire et c'est très difficile car se
méfier de ce que l'on a envie de croire
c'est lutter contre la tendance
naturelle de notre cerveau il faut
quelque part combattre son propre
cerveau enfin il existe peut-être un
troisième conseil qui pour le coup vous
implique réellement dans votre
comportement de tous les jours
il faudrait que sur internet vous soyez
des citoyens comme vous l'êtes dans la
vraie vie
si monsieur ici au premier rang se met à
hurler que la terre est plate que la
terre est plate que la terre est plate
et bien peut-être que madame
commencerait par lui dire qu'il existe
des éléments qui prouvent que non la
terre est ronde
monsieur renchérirait avec des arguments
scientifiques des preuves et surtout au
bout d'un moment on lui demanderait
d'arrêter de hurler mais ça c'est la
vraie vie qu'est ce qui se passe sur
internet
est ce que quelqu'un ici dans la salle a
déjà pris le temps de chercher à
discuter avec un croyant sur les réseaux
sociaux
je vois certaines mines que vous y êtes
risqué vous avez donc constater à quel
point c'était difficile fatiguant voire
carrément insupportable et surtout vous
avez constaté quelque chose c'est que la
force de la croyance de votre
interlocuteur et sa capacité à toujours
surenchérir avec d'autres arguments
eh bien ça lui donnait une sur
représentation dans les algorithmes et
que du coup sa croyance était bien plus
visible que vos arguments qui pourtant
était du domaine scientifique
nous sommes face à un véritable enjeu
mais un enjeu dans lequel nous avons des
solutions il faut être conscient que
toutes ces croyances vous ont fait rire
mais qu'elles peuvent aussi avoir des
conséquences dramatiques
au mois d'octobre dernier durant la
campagne présidentielle américaine
une rumeur est née accusant l'un des
deux candidats d'être le responsable le
chef d'un réseau pédophile qui opérait
depuis les sous sols d'une pizzeria de
washington au delà de l'immense buzz que
cette histoire est générée et des
dommages pour le candidat qui était
incriminé dans cette histoire c'est une
conséquence beaucoup plus grave
au début du mois de décembre après les
élections un autre jeune homme aux
croyances particulière a pris sa voiture
depuis sa caroline du nord natal et il a
roulé pendant 800 km en direction de
washington
il avait pris le soin bien entendu de
charger son coffre avec plusieurs fusils
mitrailleurs il est sorti de son
véhicule il a fait feu il a été arrêté
tout de suite il n'est heureusement bc
personne mais il a quand même pu se
rendre compte de quelque chose c'est que
dans cette pizzeria il n'y avait pas de
sous sol
pas de sous sol donc pas de réseau
pédophile en sous sol je crois
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez entendu
beaucoup de choses très intéressantes
beaucoup de gens qu'on partageait leur
croyance qui vous ont interpellé et moi
je formule le souhait qu'à la fin de
cette journée vous soyez demain des
ambassadeurs qui rompt désormais poser
la question autour de vous mais qu'est
ce que tu crois
[Applaudissements]